let's read part three together because
it's a mouthful at the harbor entrance
the difference between the water level
at high tide and low time is also six
meters what are they saying
it looks just like this it's doing this
up down in the same way it's got the
same range okay
however tides at the harbour entrance
occur an hour earlier than the wharf so
it takes some time for the wave to
actually reach and change and all that
kind of thing right in order for the
ship to be able to sail through the
shallow harbour entrance the water level
must be at least 2 meters above the low
tide level question what is 2 meters
above the low tide level low tide is 4
so 2 meters above that is 6 and I'm
going to that seems like important
information I'm going to pop that onto
my graph something like this there's my
safe level okay the ship takes 20
minutes to sail from the wharf to the
harbor entrance and it must be out to
sea by 7:00 a.m. what is the latest time
the ship can leave the wharf
ok now I started out this question by
saying hey can you help me write down
let's just look at every piece of
information and write everything down
down that's important ok in this case
here everything is also important but it
starts to get lost in the fog of oh my
goodness it goes somewhere it has to its
earlier you have to change time zones
that kind of thing so something that
will be really important is to say I
just did part 1 & 2 and now it's part 3
they clearly want me to use the stuff
that I worked out earlier to solve this
right now the equation that they went to
all the trouble for us to prove was the
water depth where where is it look at
the question read carefully it's the
water depth at the wharf there it is
right there ok but now suddenly we have
to think about the water depth at the
where is it the harbor entrance so these
are going to be slightly different but
since I have gone to all the effort of
using you know creating this equation
using it I'm going to think about this
situation and then all the other stuff
with regard to time I will take into
account afterwards that is not the only
way you have to do this you can do this
question you could adjust and have a
whole new equation for the time
at Harbor a trans but a lot of people
you just it's very confusing so let's
use the equation we already have and try
and work out the time afterwards okay so
part three run car let's start this out
safe water depth is 6 meters so just
like I did before I'm going to go ahead
and find when is the water at the at the
wharf going to be that 6 meters just
like I worked it out for when it's going
to be 8.5 okay now it's going to start
exactly the same way 7 plus 3 cos 4 PI T
on 25 equals 6 I'm gonna write that down
but then I am going to skip forward a
little bit because I think you guys can
come up with this answer what did I just
say 6 once you go ahead and go all the
way through you get 2 I'll write this
part not do I have negative yes think
about that okay so after some
simplifying you get 2 here unfortunately
unlike 1/2 this is not an exact value so
you're going to have to reach for your
calculator to get an answer out okay
should I be in degrees or radians
I should be in radians there are at
least two obvious reasons why you can
know radians
you want to give me one of them said
again yeah
calculus thank you when we're doing
motion simple harmonic motion and
projectile and straight line it's part
of the super topic applications of
calculus to the physical world so you
know we haven't done it in this clicker
question but we differentiate we
integrate you gotta be in radians
there's one other big flashing clue that
you've been in radians though there is
right that kind of signals to you right
so I'm in radians when you go and make
sure your calculators in that mode and
you press shift cause you're going to
get something for this has anyone got it
anyone got the angle that you get I
think you should be getting one point
nine one something or other from memory
can someone confirm that for me yeah you
happy okay so you got there this is
closed universe of negative 1/3 okay but
of course that's not
tea it's a it's this stuff with tea so
I'm gonna have to multiply through by
the appropriate number like this okay
so this gives us a value can someone
find that value for us yeah three point
eight zero zero two dot okay now this
graph has served its purpose you can see
where I'm trying to get to so I'm going
to get rid of it now now what does this
tell us this tells us when the Worf
depth is going to be at the six meters
okay but I actually need the six meters
to happen somewhere else at the harbor
entrance so if this is if this is a time
what time is it represent if that's in
hours what time is it on the clock three
hours and this is three hours and 48
minutes I think so so this is counting
from 2 a.m. I go forward into the future
right so at what is that 548 at 5:48
a.m. now I'm going to use words here
okay
words take a long time to write but they
clarify what's happening and they help
me know what to do next
okay at 5:48 a.m. the wharf has a six
meter water depth that's what we just
went and worked out this equation that
we started with was at the wharf and I
said I want it to be six that's what's
happening now go look at the question
again what is the relationship between
the wharfs time and the harbor entrances
time really carefully
hmm
second sentence can you read it with me
however tied at the harder entrance
occur one hour earlier then at the wharf
so 548 it's 6 meters at the wharf but
this happened an hour ago at the harbour
entrance where it really matters so what
time is an hour ago 448 right this is
not the wharf anymore this is the
harbour entrance which is where I'm
actually interested in okay so now I
know when it happens there but it takes
me some time to get to the harbour
entrance right I leave in I can't leave
it this time by the time I get there
it's over how long does it take me to
get there
read the question last sentence isn't it
no second last sorry before the actual
question their ship takes 20 minutes to
get there if I want to reach the harbour
entrance at that time because that's the
last moment it's safe I have to leave 20
minutes earlier than that right so I can
say therefore ship whoops that's a funny
yes
ship must leave what's 20 minutes
earlier than that for 28 a.m. that's a
really bad l there we go okay have we
answered the question looks okay to me I
haven't just provided a time in terms of
hours I've actually looked at the time
on the clock it doesn't mean all the
conditions required because there
actually was one piece of information in
the question that I haven't referred to
you up until now there's a 7 a.m. now
why do you think they put that in there
the ship must leave must be out to sea
by 7:00 a.m. what difference is a Meg
yes when we have a look over here right
remember we had to talk about the
earliest solution because there's not
just that solution there are the ones
that happen later on there will be times
later that it can leave but if we have a
look at the next time we get a solution
it's going to be well way after 7:00
a.m. so all that 7:00 a.m. domain
restriction is about is to lock you in
to the earliest time does that make
sense now exhale have a look at the
working that's on the board how hard is
this how would you rate this on a scale
from one to ten this is the harness
stuff that you do it I don't think this
is anywhere close to the hardest stuff
that you do some of those integrals
similar is proof by induction this thumb
truce that we did in in you're just most
recent tests sometimes make your eyes
water compared to this like this is well
apart from the radians you could do this
in your tents solve a trigonometric
equation okay but what's hard is all of
this interpretation their willingness to
look and actually use words and work out
how do these times relate to each other
that's why this question was so
disastrous disastrously done at the hoc
okay so take the time to read you must
pay close attention to the wording
another question and there's a good
chance that's somewhere within
applications of calculus to the physical
world even if it's not in simple
harmonic maybe they'll be projectile
maybe it'll be exponential growth in K
you will get a question like this and
you will need to practice that skill of
interpretation okay